I think all we really need and it's not
a postulate it's implicit in behavior I
think it's implicit in animal behavior I
was very impressed with that TED talk by
Fran Stovall's he has the capuchin
monkey uh great great thing you gotta
watch it he's uh there's this monkey and
first he's given cucumbers he's right
next door to another monkey he whom he
can see he's given cucumbers perfectly
happy with the cucumbers and he sees his
next-door neighbour monkey has gotten
grapes the next time he gets the
cucumber he throws it in the
experimenters face he's that's
interesting I don't see the relevance of
it toward trying to fashion any kind of
moral philosophy I'm the animal I mean
you could equally well say well look at
lions you know the male lion sits and
eats and fornicates and the he has a
pride of female lions that go out and do
all the work it's a it's a I mean
perhaps this feels right to lie I
suppose it does and there may be good
evolutionary reasons why lions behave
this way but it's a an example that we
would shine I mean finding here in their
behavior which we sort of recognize as
having some showing animals having some
sense of fairness doesn't show us that
we should be fair in that sense or no it
doesn't but what it shows is that of
animals reach a certain level
consciousness they have a sense that
their their stuff coming to them and
that there are certain emotions that
come out of that which are you know of
unfairness etc and that um that it seems
to me gets normativity
into it already that there is that that
notion of when a thing is treated a
certain way there was a reason not to
treat it that way and that that animal
if it reaches some level of
sophistication especially with language
can actually articulate this I mean
anybody who's raised children know it's
at about two-and-a-half or three they're
articulating well you know that's not
fair so that the commitment to oneself
very quickly evolves into a notion of of
there are reasons that I shouldn't be
treated this way
and that seems to me you already get
normativity and we can we can't live our
lives without it whether it's it's
unavoidable but those other moral
emotions purity believe me you can talk
yourself out of it I have no trouble
with Pig anymore loyalty group Authority
you can talk yourself out of all of that
stuff and I have right but this one that
you know that if I think that I matter
and my life is impossible without my
thinking I matter I just wouldn't act at
all I would plan for my future I
wouldn't do anything if I think I matter
that's already getting normativity onto
the page it seems to me and you can and
then we've got a footing we can expand
well I don't know how you talked
yourself out of group loyalty I mean I
have a feeling that it is right to be
loyal to your group within limits go
ahead talk me out of it I don't I don't
know how you can do that it is not based
on any reasoned judgment that this will
make the world a better place
it just seems right to me and I and I
deny the capability of reason to to
change my mind about a second I think
that there is quite a bit of that I
agree with that about what you said
particularly the criticism of sam Harris
and utilitarianism although that has
been done very nicely on philosophical
grounds and of course do turns are there
have their own
come back you know it's it gets a really
complicated literature immediately but
for instance one when you said I I think
that I have that are Oh morally Oh more
loyalty to let's say my friends and
family and all that there are there are
these there are ethical frameworks that
do fit that kind of view that's virtue
ethics from communitarianism for
instance which I happen to work virtue
ethics and communitarianism are exactly
that kind of thing so moral philosophy
moral reasoning in philosophy is not a
way to ground anything on the basis of
some kind of bedrock nor is it a way to
provide sort of universal answers I
think not any more trees I mean
philosophers tried that for a while I
think it's a form of reasoning it's like
okay there is a large literature on how
to think these things through you you do
have to start with certain assumptions
and actions that can be questioned but
that's true for everything we do it's
true in science is true in mathematics
is to enlarge X so why wouldn't be
between in in ethics and then there are
better and worse ways to reason your way
through things so if you wanna for
instance a very good example of how
practical moral philosophical reasoning
works I think you can take a look at the
last two books by Michael Sandel who
basically excuse ultra broad talk about
you know reason you to journalism that
is better or the ontology or whatever it
is it just starts each chapter in those
books with an actual question and in
reason is way through
possible answers and and it's a it's
attics becomes a way of tool to figure
out certain certain things yes there are
limits now in answer to your question
about you know what kind of reasoning
could possibly make me overcome you know
example BIA well there are there are
attempts they are doing a phobia right
well you know so distrust of other
groups mean that's that's that's the
idea well there is their reasons there
too there is attempts they are to know
Peter singers
concept of an expanding circle is based
on the idea that yes we start with the
local group because that is the natural
thing to do it comes from the fact that
we're social primates and all that but
then we think about any said well
although I have an instinctual reaction
to where somebody looks different from
me if I think of if I stop and think
about it which is what philosophy
coefficient is supposed to make you do I
don't have any actual reason to believe
that that person is in fatty fear or
dangerous or inherently so and therefore
why should I trade him if I'm sorry I I
don't accept this
the I don't I'm not loyal to my family
because I think other families are worse
obvious I distrust them will fear them
I'm loyal to my family because they're
my family and I think that's something I
ought to do now I don't as I say it's
not an absolute thing I would sacrifice
some interest of my family for really
great welfare of everyone but I don't I
don't see any rational process that
tells me how to make those trade-offs
you